well john for some kids it's their first
time ever in a classroom the first day
of school will look
of course a lot different this week for
students all across the valley bianca
holman continues our team coverage now
with reaction from parents hey bianca
good morning
hey good morning alex remember the days
when you can walk your kids to their
classroom show them their desk show them
their cubby
yeah no more those days are gone parents
are going to have to drop off their
student at
the curb or at their gate if they're
walking and then say their goodbyes
there and it's of course for safety
reasons so it's an adjustment for
parents and students who are going to be
headed back to school
this morning and we were actually able
to talk with one family
and jennifer seisman a ccsd parent who
has a child in kindergarten
she lives in the southwest part of the
valley and says her child's school was
very active with the online learning
providing resources with supplies
but having a child who was recently
diagnosed with adhd
in person learning she says is more
beneficial for him
it's really difficult to get a
five-year-old
he's often online five times throughout
the day
so he gets into playing with his toys
and then you have to get him back online
so you know 15 minutes later
so he that's a really hard concept
especially for a five-year-old
she also shares that her son will have a
small class size of course for social
distancing and
now he has two different teachers seeing
one in person and the other virtually
until they go back to full time in april
and like most parents seismic says that
she does have questions about what that
full-time structure will look like and
social distancing and how that will all
play out
and of course as we learn more
information we will be sure to share it
with you all back to you guys in the
studio